Genome, DNA, chromosome, homologous,
diploid, haploid, genes, alleles, and
chromatids. The field of genetics uses
a whole bunch of words specific to this
area of biology. Are you overwhelmed?
Well, let's take a guided tour to
understand what they all mean and how
they fit together. First, the genome.
This is all of the genetic material of
an organism. The human genome holds
many clues as to how we look and behave,
but there's so much information there
that we still don't understand most of
it. It's a huge area of ongoing
research. For most organisms, this
genetic information is made up of DNA.
DNA, or deoxyribonucleic acid, is the
storage structure for our biological
information. It is made of smaller
units called bases. These are the
famous A, T, C, and Gs. Three billion
of them strung together on a backbone
of sugar and phosphate. The DNA is
organized in two strands that fit
together in a double helix. The genome
of humans is divided into several very
long DNA double helices, each of which
is called a chromosome.
The DNA of different humans are
incredibly similar, but not identical,
except for identical twins. And these
differences make each of us unique.
Each living organism has a
characteristic number of chromosomes.
Humans, for example, have twenty two
pairs of autosomal chromosomes, each of
them unique in size and sequence, and
two types of sex chromosomes, X and Y.
Most of our cells, apart from sperm or
eggs, have pairs of similar chromosomes.
This makes us, overall, diploid
organisms. These pairs of chromosomes,
which are called homologous
chromosomes, are very similar but not
identical, as one is from mom and one
is from dad. The human sperm and egg,
which are called gametes, are different
in that they only have one copy of each
autosomal chromosome and carry only one
sex chromosome. Having just one copy
makes gametes haploid.
When a sperm fertilizes an egg, there
are now twenty three pairs of
chromosomes, or forty six in total. The
fertilized egg then divides making the
many cells of the human body. Now let's
look more closely at this process of
cell division, which is also called
mitosis. As a cell prepares to divide,
each DNA molecule is replicated,
resulting in two identical copies of
each chromosome. This means that the
forty six chromosomes temporarily
double to ninety two chromosomes in
each cell. The two exact copies of each
chromosome are called sister chromatids.
Initially, the sister chromatids are
connected to each other at a central
point, which is often depicted as the
X-shaped drawing of a chromosome. At
the end of mitosis, the two sister
chromatids detach and are pulled apart
in opposite directions. Two daughter
cells are created, each with forty six
chromosomes and the exact same genome,
So let's look closer at the structure
of a chromosome. Within the long DNA
strand, there are regions called genes
that contain the instructions to make
proteins. There are around twenty two
thousand protein coding genes in humans.
The proteins that genes code for make
us who we are, they give us ginger hair
or be blood type O. These traits are
also called phenotypes in the field of
genetics.
Zooming back out to the chromosome
level once again, we can start to
understand where variation in human
phenotype begins. As humans have pairs
of homologous chromosomes, it follows
that they also have pairs of genes. A
pair of genes may be identical to one
another, or they may differ subtly in
their DNA sequences, in which case
they are called alleles. Sometimes
different alleles still give rise to
the same phenotype. If the two genes on
homologous chromosomes produce the same
phenotype, for example, both causing
blue eyes, the person is homozygous for
that phenotype. However, sometimes the
two alleles produce different
phenotypes, for example, blue eyes and
brown eyes. This makes a person
heterozygous.
The actual outcome in the person, for
example, what eye color they end up
with, depends on whether one allele is
dominant over the other. For example,
the allele for brown eyes is dominant
over blue, so the person will have
brown eyes. The blue allele is
recessive because it has no effect on
the phenotype of the heterozygote.
Most phenotypes, however, are not as
simply explained and understood as eye
color. Height, intelligence, and
susceptibility to different diseases,
for example, are complex blends of
numerous genes and their many alleles.
Phew! Now that we've covered all of
these different terms involving DNA, we
can delve into all of the amazing
things that DNA does and understand how
the study of genetics is
revolutionizing medicine and advancing
our knowledge of life.